hello everybody and once again a very
warm welcome to this new tutorial on a
competition that we have just published
and this time we're looking to Select
Staff in different fields related to
finance
accounting and digital communication
it's an ASD or an assistant competition
on level asd3 which I will explain in a
minute
this competition as you may know if you
have followed previous tutorials is
published on our website and on this
website on the landing page of the
competition we always publish this
infographic
basically in one blink of an eye you see
the procedure of the competition with
the different steps explained and
through this tutorial I will give you
some more in-depth information on these
different steps
first of all for this competition
actually there are six different fields
as you can see on this slide so there's
field number one financial management
and there's a second field uh accounting
and Treasury and there's public
procurement
graphic design and visual content
production then social media and digital
media and then we're also looking for
webmasters
you see the number of successful
candidates mentioned here quite a big
competition again overall we're looking
to select close to 500 successful
candidates so quite substantial
so pick your field as you can see you
can only apply for one field out of D6
so think well what relates best to your
qualities and competencies
the eligibility criteria for an ast3
competition are always rather the same
so you need at least
uh post-secondary education in the field
or relevant to the field of the
competition plus three years of relevant
experience in the field
or you need just secondary education
plus six years of experience in the
field and when I say experience in the
field of course it has to relate to one
of those six fields and that the
competition is about and you'll find
that the detailed explanation of this
relevance in the notice of competition
which is the legal document explaining
the whole competition very detailedly
which we have published right now also
on our website
then as usual there's also a language
Criterium you need to speak to EU
languages one on Level C one at least
and one on level B2 at least
one of these two languages must be
English the other one can be any of the
23 remaining official EU languages
the selection procedure always looks
quite the same again if you would have
seen already tutorials of previous
competitions
the system looks quite alike so first
you have to apply of course and once you
have applied you will be invited to a
first stage of testing during which we
test the reading skills
the best performing will be invited to
the second stage which is an assessment
center during which we make you sit
three more tests
and then the successful candidates will
be listed on what we call the reserve
list and this is the basis for
recruitment by the different
institutions who will pick you and offer
you a job
so let's have a closer look to these
different steps as I said first of all
you need to apply how do you do that you
need an Excel account if you do not have
one yet you can create one on our
website very easily if you already have
one do use that account do not create a
second one because you're not allowed to
do so you can only have one account for
all your applications also for future
opportunities I always use that that
same account
you apply it on our website on the home
page you find the link to this
competition you can fill it out in any
other 24 official languages and you
should validate your application at the
latest on the 25th of October
uh prior to that time you can go in and
out your application as you wish as long
as you save your data nothing it gets
lost but at the end of course you need
to validate that application and by
sending it to us
um and that you can do only at or at the
latest on the 25th of October
everybody who applies will be invited to
this first step of reasoning skills now
since this competition has six different
fields
this stage is a bit different depending
on for which field you have applied so
as you can see this slide shows you the
reading skills procedure for Fields one
and two and then you'll see later on
there's a slight difference for the
fields three four five and six you see
there's a slight difference
what is the difference about for Fields
one and two so Finance or financial
management and accounting and Treasury
um there are as usual three tests to sit
numerical reasoning verbal reasoning and
abstract reasoning and for these two
Fields the numerical reasoning is
separate from the two others so you need
a separate pass score of 8 out of 15 in
this case for numerical reasoning
and then as you can see there is a
combined pass Mark for verbal and
abstract reasoning and there you need 12
out of 25 okay you set these reading
skills tests not in English so in your
other language all right
the difference for Fields three four
five and six is that here the verbal
reasoning is separate you need a
passcore of 10 out of 20 for your verbal
reasoning and then there is a combined
pass Mark for numerical and abstract
reasoning also the number of questions
and the duration and the scoring is a
bit different as you can see here but
all that is explained again in detail in
the notes of competition
I do advise you to train this well and
you can do so by having a look at our
sample test you see the link below on
this slide as well we offer sample tests
in all languages for you to train this
and if you train these kind of of
questions and and tests you will get
better at this so I really advise you to
go there and have a look if you think
about participating in this competition
I said the best performing will be
invited to a second stage
which is an assessment center and in the
assessment center we first test a set of
General competencies and then some also
field related competencies of course
so first a word about the general
competencies
um there are seven of them as you can
see on this slide here and we test these
competencies by or through two tests
there's a case study to be done which is
a written exercise
and this case study will test four
competencies as you can see here
and then you will set a situational
Competency Based interview which will
assess three more competencies this
interview is basically an interview
where we want to see how you react in a
given work related situation okay again
you will find sample tests on our sample
test page so again have a look there to
see what this looks like
the assessment center is always done in
English so all tests as from now will be
taken in English
for each competency you can get up to 10
points and you need a combined pass Mark
of 35 out of 70.
then of course we also test your field
related competency again in English and
that is based or done through an
interview you can get up to 100 points
here you need at least 50 and of course
the interview is related to one of these
six Fields the one that you have chosen
of course
the successful candidates are listed in
a big database and this is as I said in
the very beginning the the basis for
recruitment so once you are in this
database the different institutions will
consult this database and offer jobs to
different people on these lists and you
will be recruited in the months
following the publication of this list
the whole procedure can take up to 10
months so don't think that when you
apply now you will start working with us
in say January or so it's not the case
it takes quite long because as you may
know
we Select Staff from all over the EU so
we test these different candidates in
different languages
in different time slots most of the
tests actually actually all of the tests
can be taken remotely so you do not need
to travel to take these tests if you
wish so the reasoning skills test can be
taken in a test center in your country
but you can also choose to sit it online
from home the assessment center tests
are always taken remotely so from home
for your best convenience all that again
will be explained to you when you get to
the different steps by communication
from episode
all right
so again I can only
um stress again and advise you to read
the notice of competition very carefully
this document you find it now on the
apply page of this competition it gives
you all the detailed information on the
different steps on the on the job
description as well on everything you
need to prepare so have a look there to
to get to to be really well prepared in
advance for this competition
if you have any more questions you can
reach out to us we have a team available
that answers all your questions through
the contact form on our website
if everything is clear and you're ready
please do apply and I wish you all the
success in this competition and hope to
meet you soon at least some of you as a
future colleague thanks for your
attention and see you at the next
occasion bye